our object is thus from now on the
syllogism which has for its extremes the
inner being of things and the
understanding and for its middle term
appearance but the movement of this
syllogism yields the further
determination of what the understanding
describes in this inner world through
the middle term and the experience from
which understanding learns about the
close linked unity of these terms
paragraph 145 might seem a little
puzzling at first when you see Hegel
talking about this term of the syllogism
that's a term that's used in logic and
it's it's good to remember that Hegel is
engaged in something that is logical but
it's in a rather different sense than
the kinds of logics that we tend to
teach in say a logic course which tend
to be either Aristotelian logic or we
nowadays call modern formal logic we
don't generally teach any dialectical
logic and even the dialectical logic
that that marks us like to to work with
isn't quite the same thing as Hegel's
understanding of logic now I'm gonna say
something else that takes us a little
bit outside of the phenomenology as well
and that's Hegel he does talk about this
in the preface to the phenomenology says
that the phenomenology itself when it's
fully articulated is providing us with a
logic with a logo so low geek' of
reality as such right even encompassing
the the thinker the conscious person
within that reality so he's going to
write to other works later on that are
called logics one is not long after the
phenomenology and it is called the
science of logic as a very long dense
work not as much people giving attention
to that these days in comparison to the
phenomenology in the 20th and 21st
century but as well worth reading and he
will say some things about syllogism in
that work that I'm gonna bring up in
just a moment that will help you give it
some context the other thing that he
talks about as being a logic is what's
referred to as the Encyclopaedia logic
and that is where he's sort of laying
out his entire system within a pretty
schematic form in many respects and that
also you might say interfaces with the
phenomenology of spirit now going back
to the science of logic
Hegel will say in the section that he
devotes to the syllogism because he has
a whole discussion of the syllogism
there that the syllogism is you might
say the eminent device of rationality
that judgments by themselves concepts by
themselves the play of appearance by
itself is not yet fully rational and
anything that is rational will in some
respect the asila jism so right there
that ought to put you on your guard
against thinking something like this
when we hear syllogism we've gotten
conditioned those of us who say teach
logic or who've taken logic classes to
thinking that the term syllogism
necessarily refers to you know an
argument that is articulated using three
terms you know a predicate subject with
coppola you know that is in between that
we can represent with Venn diagrams or
stuff like that and and then syllogism
in its classic sense the way that
Aristotle actually uses the term outside
of saying you know the two analytics and
in his broader work in the topics and
the rhetoric and stuff like that he's
talking about cyllage izing or sulig
osmose what he means there is a
connected chain of reasoning that is
bringing things together and has some
sort of middle term which allows us to
connect things to see into things to see
the relations between things so he'll
talk about cyllage izing as something
for example that the rudder is
particularly good at doing and it can
even be connected with metaphor and
that's productive activity Hegel is
viewing it like that so you know usually
when we talk about a syllogism we mean
that there's two terms and those are the
premises and though that this term is
term one is related to the middle term
in some way term two is related in the
middle term in some way and then what we
get is our conclusion is term one is
connected with term one in some way they
don't always have to be in this order as
far as you know like this way but they
do have to be an order
why and what's important is that the
middle term you might say drops out
right so the middle term is not there in
the conclusion Hegel in discussing this
is not presuming that the syllogism
works just that way as a matter of fact
it wouldn't make any sense to talk about
you know things totally dropping out or
disappearing just having the conclusion
instead he is going to say our object
right what it is that we're studying is
thus from now on the syllogism which has
for its extremes so here's the two
extremes extreme one extreme to those
would be corresponding to term one in
term two over there the two extremes are
the intervening of things what we've
been looking at in these previous
passages what's being mediated by
appearance or the play of forces right
and the understanding so we've got the
understanding and the interviewing of
things as the two extremes and what's
mediating them is appearance now why is
it a syllogism because there is a
process of rationality we just saw that
reason now it's coming on the scene and
rationality is taking part within this
this framework within this this dynamic
relation so he said the movement of this
syllogism notice movement of this
syllogism yields the further
determination it's good it's going to
show us some things the further
determination of what the understanding
finds in this inner world right the
understanding through appearance is
finding something out about the inner
world and in relation to that the
experience from which understanding
learns about the closed length of unity
of these terms so understanding itself
is accomplishing something in its work
going through appearance to the inner
being of things understanding is
grasping something not only about the
inner being of things but also about
itself that is actually taking
understanding from the level of just
understand
to the level of rationality that we've
looked at just in the last section
the inner world is for consciousness
still appear beyond because
consciousness does not as yet find
itself in it it is empty for it is
merely the nothingness of appearance and
positively the simpler unitary universal
this mode of the inner being of things
finds ready acceptance by those who say
that the inner being of things is
unknowable but another reason for this
would have to be given certainly we have
no knowledge of this inner world as it
is here in its immediacy but not because
reason is too short-sighted or is
limited or however one else likes to
call it on this point we know nothing is
yet because we have not yet gone deep
enough but because of the simple matte
nature of the matter at hand
that is to say because in the void
nothing is known or expressed from the
other side just because this inner world
is determined as the beyond of
consciousness the result is of course
the same as if a blind man is placed at
mid the wealth of the supersensible
world if it has such wealth whether it
be its own peculiar content or whether
consciousness itself be this content and
if one with sight is placed in pure
darkness or if you like in pure light
just supposing this super sensible world
to be like this so the man with sight
sees as little in that pure light as in
pure darkness and just as much as the
blind man in the abundant wealth which
lies before him if no further
significance attached to the inner world
and to our close let link with it
through the world of appearance then
nothing would be left to us but to stop
at the world of appearance that is to
perceive something as true which we know
is not true or in other in order that
there may be something in the void which
though it first came about is devoid of
objective things must however is empty
in itself be taken it be taken as also
void of all spiritual relationships and
distinctions of consciousness as
consciousness qua consciousness in order
then that in this complete void which is
even called the holy of holies there may
yet be something we must fill it up with
reveries appearances produced by
consciousness itself it would have to be
content with being treated so badly for
it would not deserve anything better
since even reveries are better than its
emptiness
so if section 146 is supposed to be a
syllogism in some sort of you know
classic Aristotelian sense of the term
or even the modern logic sense of the
term you're going to have a very
difficult time trying to figure out how
to cram it into all of that instead what
we have to see is the relationship
between again the two extreme terms the
consciousness or the understanding in
this case also reason and this inner
world and what we're going to see
happening in this this particular
paragraph is consciousness being told
you need to do a bit more work you need
to work a bit harder before you say
anything about what's in there
next section is going to give us some
clues about that but we want to see the
problematic that Hegel's laying out here
so he says the inner world for
consciousness is still a pure beyond we
don't yet know what the in itself of
things holds for us
consciousness why doesn't find itself in
it consciousness is actually there in it
as we've seen in previous paragraphs but
it has not realized yet that it is there
so it's going to try to explore a bit on
its own part of what could be in there
and it's going to come up with some as
Hegel's gonna put it not quite in those
terms but let's let's call a spade a
spade
some crazy speculations about what's
what's in there so he says it's empty
for it's merely the nothingness of
appearance we've got appearance here
what we can grasp what we can make sense
of it subjective for us and then we have
us beyond this inner world which could
be the super sensible world that we're
talking about just two paragraphs before
as well we have the world of appearance
the phenomenal world and then we have
let's just come out and say it Kant's
new middle world right the the world
that we can think but can't really know
the world in which we can perhaps engage
by action by willing but about which we
can have no reliable representations
so it doesn't necessarily have to be
done in a conscious way although Hegel
is sort of you know platforming LOF of
that in this case it could be any case
where we're saying there's some sort of
world beyond there's something beyond
the appearances but we can't really
figure out what it what it is and why
not that's the key question here he says
this mode of interbeing of things finds
ready acceptance by those who say the
inner being of things is unknowable so
it's going to appeal to people who are
you know involved in critical philosophy
it's going to appeal to people who are
you know when it comes to science not
the people who are the you know big
believers in science will solve anything
but the people who actually understand
the limits of science that it's
restricted essentially to the phenomenal
world and what we can conclude from it
it's also going to peel the people who
have a kind of certain kind of mystic
tendency who want to say now you know
there's just there's just some
unknowable unsaleable thing beyond that
we can't really get it let's just call
it the void because that's what Hegel is
getting to college and there's people
who do do that we've already seen
Hegel's criticisms of them in the
preface he says another reason would
need to be given he's not going to
accept that sort of reasoning why not
how do you know there's a void in there
who told you that there is something
like that what do you actually mean by
it if you can't conceive of it if you
can't say it this is one of the problems
with anybody who wants to make a
recourse to that sort of mysticism
mysticism meaning you know the dealing
with the mystery that which is hidden
that which is concealed Hegel would say
look unless you can unconcealed it a
little bit you have no idea what's there
and you probably ought to keep your
mouth shut you know he probably would be
willing to say hey if you want to be
tracked on as Vidkun Stein and say that
there a week we cannot speak we have to
be silent you go on ahead but don't
expect anybody else to be silent and
don't think that
I'm gonna be silent as a result because
I actually has some confidence in the
power of reason I'm not going to accept
the limits that have been placed on it
because those limits themselves
seemingly coming from reason are and are
themselves actually not fully rational
so he says
certainly we don't have any knowledge of
this inner world as it is here in its
immediacy but not because reason is too
short-sighted not because reason is
itself too limited as we're going to see
Hegel often will say when there's a
limit in place how do you know that
limit is in place you have to already be
beyond the limit to a certain extent in
order to see the limit there you have to
implicitly transgress the limit to
observe the limit and Hegel says the
same thing about reason he says on this
point we know nothing is yet because we
have not yet gone deep enough not
because reason is totally incapable but
because the people who have used reason
up till this point have not gone far
enough with it or perhaps if there are
some who have gone far enough with it
Hegel certainly thinks that there are
some people like this we haven't
actually paid attention to them and
taken into account what they had to tell
us perhaps in part because it would have
required a lot of work on our part to
get to where they they were able to take
reason reason is not something that
you're given once and for all like a
toolbox or you know a package of candies
instead of something think of it like a
muscle that works upon itself that has
to develop itself through the very
activity of working so he says the
simple nature of the matter in hand that
is to say because in the void nothing is
known or expressed from the other side
just because this inner world has
determined is beyond of consciousness we
have decided or arrived at the point
where we say look there's I don't know
what's there
you know let's just call it the X or the
null set or the empty we don't really
know we have to work in order to get
there and so he says the results if we
want to make a comparison is just the
same as if a blind man is placed among
is placed amid the wealth of the
supersensible world if it has such such
wealth whether it be its own peculiar
content or whether consciousness itself
be this content and if one with sight is
placed in pure darkness or if you like
in pure light when we have pure darkness
of course you can't see anything when we
have light that that is sufficiently
bright we can't see anything either
this by the way is a metaphor that goes
all the way back in time to the you know
great ancient and medieval thinkers
Saint Anselm talks about the metaphor of
our view on the divine as not being that
the divine is itself obscure or dark but
rather that it is so bright it is so
blinding the inaccessible light in which
God dwells is one that we are not
capable of seeing through in part
because there's a super abundance of
intelligibility a super abundance of
content a super abundance of
illumination so he compares us to Isles
where he actually compares the
dialectician to owls who think that you
know because they they can't really see
in sunlight there's nothing there to see
candles saying the same thing about this
he goes on and he says the man with
sight sees as little in the pure light
as in pure darkness so you know it could
be that it's a void it could be that
it's a wealth of content that we're just
not able to process we're just not able
to take in we're not able to make
intelligible for ourselves on this end
at least not yet later on we actually
will but that takes development that
takes process that takes building that
takes build um an education or formation
right so he's going to go on and he says
if no further significance attached to
the inner world in our close link with
it through the
the parents if we weren't able to get to
through appearance as we're gonna see
you talked about in the next paragraph
then nothing would be left but to stop
at the world of appearance we could say
all right there's a limit here we can't
get beyond that there there may be
something beyond that but we're just
gonna observe that and say that stuff
over there that's not for us human
beings should think human thoughts and
not divine thoughts right we leave that
part over there but that would be the
consequence if we were to do that we
would live a life that would in some
respects be alienated from what is most
important or we wouldn't even know
whether it's most important because we
wouldn't have gotten over here to see
what's actually there this is not just
you know wanderlust you know wanting to
see what's over the next mountain pass
this is wanting to see what is under all
the mountains all together for Hegel
this is you could say and this is not
something that's in the text but this is
sort of the the prototypical
Enlightenment idea if indeed we take
consecrate all day you know dare to know
not just deer to think not just deer to
say but deer - no - to taste to be wise
about things Hegel was saying yes that's
exactly what we should do it
so he says or in order that there may be
something in the void if we don't just
observe this limit and say oh nothing we
can say about that and live a life that
seems to be devoid of anything
transcendent if we say well you know we
can't live without it we need something
there
he says the void seems to be devoid of
objective things it's empty it's also
taken as void of all spiritual
relationships distinctions of
consciousness qua consciousness if we're
going to think of it as a complete void
then what happens then we call it the
holy of holies we treated it with this
utmost sort of respect right and people
want to say
well you know emptiness or the unsayable
or you know the origin or or the end
point or something like that and what's
going to happen then human beings to
have a tendency not only to try to get
in every door that's closed and to try
to you know transgress limits but also
to project things into the places that
they leave empty so avoid can't really
stay avoid he's going to say what's
gonna happen here is they're going to
fill it up with referees referees you
know daydreams images appearances
produced by consciousness itself in
Hegel would be willing to say that this
is what goes on in most philosophies
that establish this sort of limit and
then say hands off over here but this is
vitally important they end up shooting
something in there and saying well
that's what's there but the problem with
that is there's no real necessity not
only have they sort of denied the
appearances of things and the importance
of those because you know guess what our
connection with the inner world is going
to be through appearances they also take
certain appearances on their own part or
certain imaginations and then they shoot
those in there and turn those into the
transcendent they turn those into the
unconditioned Universal than we've been
looking for so he says you know here's
how he concludes it would have to be
content with being treated so badly for
it would not deserve anything better
since even reveries heart better than
emptiness it's interesting isn't it to
see him talking about the void or the
inner being of things as if it has its
own sort of responsibility its own sort
of agency it will indeed have that
because consciousness it is as we
pointed out already over there but
conscious
does not realize that yet
the inner world or supersensible beyond
he has however come into being it comes
from the world of appearance which has
mediated it in other words appearance is
its essence and in fact it's filling the
supersensible is a sensuous and the
perceived positing as it is in truth but
the truth of the sensuous and the
perceived is to be appearance the
supersensible is therefore appearance
qua appearance we completely
misunderstand this if we think that the
supersensible world is therefore the
sensuous world where the world as it
exists for immediate sense certainty and
perception for the world of appearance
is on the contrary not the world of
sense knowledge and perception is a
world that positively is but this world
positives as superseded or in truth and
inner world it has often said that the
supersensible world is not appearance
but what is here understood by
appearance is not appearance but rather
the sensuous world as itself there
really actual
in 147 we arrived at a point where we
probably need to ask ourselves what's
going on here
Hegel has just talked all about this
super sensible world that is some sort
of beyond for appearances and yet it's
going to be as he's going to say
appearance as appearance or the truth of
appearance so this should give us some
pause and make us think for a bit which
is going to be very helpful as we
approach the next couple paragraphs what
is really going on here with this super
sensible world as it's going to turn out
I'm going to give you a little bit of
the foreshadowing the super sensible
world like I said previously in one of
the earlier paragraphs is not super
sensible in this in the way of being non
sensible opposed to the sensible totally
cut a lot from it rather it transcends
it in a certain way it opens up a kind
of depth within the sensible that we
were not yet capable of grasping through
consciousness but which implicitly we
were already playing off of so he says
this inner world are super sensible
beyond has come into being now what the
problem was is we didn't know what was
there right because we distinguish it
from the world of appearance which we
understand that's phenomenal you know we
want to get around in the world of
appearance we look at things we smell
them we taste them we touch them we
experience them but when it comes to
this you know what ways do we have of
opening it up and finding out what's
inside as it's going to turn out the
world of appearance is going to in if we
understand it correctly be Ramallah Tory
of the supersensible world it's not
going to be something totally sundered
from it he says it comes from the world
of appearance which has media so when
when consciousness is trying to grasp
the supersensible
well it necessarily is going to do so
through the world of appearance he says
in other words appearance is actually
its essence appearance is the essence of
the thing that seems to go beyond
appearance he says
the supersensible is the sensuous and
the perceive the things that we were
studying in the last two sections we're
now seeing enforcing the understanding
the true senses are the true meanings of
sense certainty what handled the
sensuous the immediate particular
located in space and time in our in our
you know manifold of senses and what is
perceived the thing that is grasped in
its truth its in its VAR height vara
naman means you know perception but also
grasped or grouping of truth so he says
the supersensible world is indeed these
but as they are in truth that means that
there's a death within everything that
we're perceiving or sensing that we
don't grasp just through sensitivity or
you know sense perception or through the
perception through the universal the
sensuous universal there is a beyond to
every single particular every single
thing that we run into it's not a
fascinating thing to say so he says it's
it's the sensuous and the perceived
positive as it is in truth what is the
truth of the sensuous and the perceived
to be appearance to be something that
shows itself that shines into our
experience so he says the supersensible
is appearance as appearance the
appearance qua appearance appearance as
it is something that we're going to
explore that in greater detail so he
says we completely misunderstand this if
we think that the supersensible world is
therefore the sensuous world the world
of appearance right they are different
from each other but they are not some
things totally separate from each other
you might say this is certainly the
aspect of this but really this is the
aspect of this there's a
reciprocal relation of dependency there
and as they are for consciousness so he
was only says it's not the sumptuous
world over the world as it exists for
immediate set certainty and perception
this world of appearance is grasped by
the perceiving by the sensitive human
being the person right but there's
something more to consciousness than
just that he says the world of
appearance is on the country not the
world of sense knowledge and perception
of the world that positively is but a
world posited as superseded so what
we've got going on here yes the Super
Session they've raising to a higher
level of our payment and what does that
it's going to be consciousness that
actually does that that
behind-the-scenes has been operating so
he says it's often said that the super
sensible world is not an appearance but
what is here understood by appearance is
not appearance there is appearance in
the sense of what is just there for
sense certainty and perception a lower
level and then there's appearance as it
is for consciousness consciousness that
also includes the understanding and the
Faculty of reason all of this is part of
what a human being is and it's nothing
if you can like separate them out you
know we're gonna we're going to push a
button and turn the reason on and turn
the sense certainty off it's not the way
that the human mind of the human soul or
the human personality actually works
instead all of these function together
and we can you know move from one of
these aspects to the other so he says
it's rather the sensuous world as it as
itself they're really actual so the
super sensible world is indeed the world
of appearance is indeed the world of the
sensuous and perceived it is the world
that we experience but experience with a
greater death precisely because of the
cognitive aspects that we bring to it
that make it something in some ways more
actual more real more dense in the
meaning that's available to us